imposer le masque ou non mais si la
question avec laquelle jongle le premier
ministre françois legault le directeur
de santé publique horacio arruda
ils hésitent ils ont peur de brusquer la
population monsieur legault suggéré
aujourd'hui elle est peut-être un peu
par étapes
on va parler tous avec docteur françois
marquis c'est le chef des service des
soins intensifs à l'hôpital maisonneuve
rosemont bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
s'est pas adapté aux marquis le port du
masque à votre avis est-ce que ça
devrait être obligatoire monsieur
legault aujourd'hui il évoqué au départ
peut-être d'un grand montréal peut-être
parce qu'on appelle la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais le problème qui est
la première des choses avec le lavage
des mains par cet hôtel est simple il
est inquiet cours et que ce soit un peu
plus grave car les gens m'ont rien parce
que les gens de montréal et la
montérégie se déclenche et il suffit de
une personne qui changent de région pour
apporter avec lui le virus écrit les
éclosions ce qu'il faut comprendre les
cas moins qu'on dise que les gens de la
montérégie et l'île de montréal auront
le droit de sortir de la région amou
tati faut que ça soit plus large
quelqu'un alors pour vous la nage et que
ce serait pour pour vraiment faire le
rôle du masque de protéger la population
ça devrait être de toute la province oui
parce que le problème c'est que les gens
se déplacent donc fillon nous permettent
aux gens de la fing soutenir notre
économie et notre peau imposer des
restrictions géographiques et là ça veut
dire le mot pour tout le monde un choix
poursuivre avec la compétence
ouais vous savez qu'il ya des gens qui
sont allergiques à ce qu'on leur dit
l'imposent masse tout de suite et ce bac
au point de les manifester d'ailleurs
ils sont très virulents c'est dans les
réseaux sociaux ils sont même parfois un
petit peu en colère et agressif je
dirais est-ce que ce risque là ce que
voulaient évaluer ce risque là de
braquer les gens je vois que les gens se
braque
j'ai des difficultés à comprendre
pourquoi c'était vraiment une toute
petite encoche dans nos libertés
deux concessions qu'on fait parce qu'on
vit en société ensemble de notre maison
avec des vêtements en sibérie massa ont
beau on respecte les règles la route on
arrête rousse on arrête aux eaux d'alet
obligatoire discuter sophisme du grime
et honnête ou mal le marque pour
l'instant on est à peu près à ce niveau
là c'est une question de sécurité
publique de sécurité sociale comme
arrêter ou arrêt obligatoire et c'est à
peu près où ses frusques hommes selon
des codes la rai de lumière au jeu pas
de voiture je les écoute pas mais non
c'est comme ça non mais il ya des gens
qui vont visible avez sûrement entendu
docteur marquis moi je respire pas bien
l'effet chaussée colère en pot j'ai peur
de respirer du gaz carbonique de plus
avoir de 10gen est ce que c'est vrai ce
nom c'est marc là pour comprendre que le
virus est bien là vraiment vraiment
beaucoup plus gros que les molécules
d'oxygène on va pas du tout risqué de
s'empoisonner au monoxyde de carbone va
pas non plus risquer de manquer
d'oxygène
l'élément de région et les gens sentent
vraiment plus psychologique que l'autre
chose c'est le fait d'avoir quelque
chose sur les doublages ça réchauffe
l'air qui parce que ça c'est vrai qu'il
ya délit mal de réchauffement des mets
ça peut pas vraiment nuire à la santé
et ça les gens se trouvent sont de
justification mais ccpo sont pas basés
sur rien a lancé la protection que le
masque ou miller et surtout qu'elles
offrent un autre citoyen concitoyens
sauf et quelque chose pour lesquels il
faut établir mais quand on tente de
porter le masque à le rendre obligatoire
on veut poser le porte et 24 heures sur
cd dans les lieux fermés ils ont été
quand même défini les atouts - montréal
on parle des commerces
on parle du moment où on rentre dans un
restaurant c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
va porter pendant des heures en principe
le nom sont ces travailleurs sont
attendus
il lui a fait mal mais quand les gens
qui travaillent dans les hôpitaux où ils
nous ont fait nous journée avec et mark
logue en personne encore était mort de
top est mais pour la population en
général c'est très très peu contraignant
fait seul concept
eh ben on est quand même des millions de
japonais qui nous ont montré que c'était
dangereux pour la santé oms le reçu
parce que dans les sociétés asiatiques
c'est déjà quelque chose pour des
raisons différentes qui quittait 6 min
pour réseaux il s'emporte pas mal
honnêtement c'est pas non plus un
règlement commun pour toujours c'est
l'état de régler un problème et on eu
lieu récemment
comment une éclosion pour ce faire les
hommes un groupe d'une cinquantaine de
personnes dans des endroits un de
l'effectif et à christophe auger ri tong
il imagine à montréal et il fait seul
qu'on fait est ce qu'on voit ce qu'on
observe c'est ce qu'on nous dise côté de
la santé publique c'est qu'en ce moment
on voit non aux échos chez les jeunes
particulièrement peut-être un effet
direct de l'ouverture des morts les
rassemblements dans les plages en fait
tout ce qu'on a vu dans la dernière fin
de semaine
les gens ne se sentent et vulnérables
dans votre pratique à vous lorsque vous
voyez dans votre hôpital psy au nom des
jeunes pour qui ça tourne mal la covin
qu'est ce que vous observez vivement il
y en a moins que les personnes plus
âgées
mais comme ils font beaucoup moins
attention que les personnes plus âgées
on en a eu un nombre a fait ça et les
jeunes de l'entente qui ont passé proche
de mauvais on en a eu plusieurs
des gens dans la quarantaine dans la
force de l'âge avec aucun antécédent
médical sont morts dans notre unité et
ça ça fait en sorte que comme médecin
mais comme être humain j'ai juste le
goût de l'échec et les pensées port de
rejeter une mortelle et fait quant à moi
c'est ouf irresponsable qu'elle conduit
en état d'ébriété ou de quoi porter ça
fait tout de culte et là on est à ce
niveau là présentement de bar je vous
dis qu avez-vous l'impression qu'on l'a
suffisamment dit qu'on a suffisamment
parlé d'un patch les jeunes parce que
pour combien de gens c'est une maladie
de csl 10 de maladie de gens très très
vieux très très malade qui serait
peut-être mort de toute façon dans
l'année 2020 c'est ce qu'on entend
beaucoup les gens l'inde de perdre
complètement
vue l'idée que ça peut les toucher aussi
oui malheureusement vous avez absolument
raison les gens ont comme justifiée
d'évacuer leurs craintes à l'enfance
comme un effet un espèce de prédateurs
ach slb alors que dans ma pratique j'en
ai vu beaucoup des patients qui avaient
rien à voir avec les filles at elle dit
des travailleurs de la santé des preuves
audio bing ciao les monsieur madame tout
le monde j'ai une famille où complexe
aura morceau soit étalée sur deux ou
trois générations
on le lit qu sur les autres et je ne
sais pas si moi je pensais que sa
vitesse ni assez clair pour tout le
monde
visiblement pas ouais est ce que vous
redoutez vous la deuxième vague
oui je pense qu'on a une occasion en or
l'aude de récupérer le virus là il s'en
fout des sacrifices qu'on a fait avant
lui c'est au jour le jour et finir une
chaîne ouverture il vole à rendre et on
a eu des avertissements majeur avec les
dernières des clauses ion pensez pas que
ça peut pas arriver une seconde balle
quant à moi moi et river la chose qu'on
peut faire c'est moduler sont importants
ouais est-ce que ça me décourage un peu
de voir qu'il ya des gens qui croient
pas ou qui veulent plus en entendre
parler honnêtement puis pour toutes les
tutelles de santé c'est extrêmement
démoralisant défaut j'en parle avec mes
infirmières et qui est lourde ont porté
les enquêtes américaine
ils auront laissé des marques d'un usage
qui y vivent mais quoi il ya personne
que compris le défaut de mateille
arrivera là il y en eu la grippe a ou
dans les phares comme gmail mobile web
écouter on va dire courage courage à vos
équipes
merci d'être là bien entendu et merci
beaucoup pour l'entrevue docteur marquis
la flip phone au revoir